and that is the story about the one time
i saw snooki at the cheesecake factory
what that is oh my gosh you guys our
emmy show with predictions fashion and
special guest starts in less than 30
seconds
wait wait the stage isn't ready drew
this year's host is cedric the
entertainer and he's waiting on us and
plus where's the audience yeah and i'm
not in the right outfit no
okay you know what
[Applause]
sunny hollywood and i'm joined by my
dearest friends it's our fellow hosts of
entertainment tonight michelle turner
and kevin frasier hi guys
and
as usual i got a hot date
hi everybody
all right let's get this party started
let's do this
the 73rd emmy awards aired this sunday
september 19th on cbs so today we're
going to break down the history yes
and of course the fashion please now
kevin this is a standout you're in many
ways i'd love you to explain to everyone
why yeah well it's important because i
feel like the emmy nominations look like
the country and what we're watching 46
people of color nominated
and i also i look at gene smart
my favorite show and i also look at
someone like mj rodriguez the first
trans person nominated in uh lead
actress in a drama category phenomenal
deserving well deserved and and it's
awesome we're back
we're back we're here you're going right
carpenter come on blackberry
carpet let's go let's go and speaking of
the red carpet one of the main reasons
people tune into the emmys is for the
fashions
let's take a look at some of the most
iconic emmy fashion moments ever i love
this
the emmy awards are one of
entertainment's biggest nights in
fashion even if you don't take home a
trophy you can still win it on the red
carpet
when the emmy's first broadcast went
national back in the 1950s people like
lucille balls set the stage for fashion
standards in the 60s people saw a lot of
peace love and flower power and the 80s
were all about the hair
by the time the 90s rolled around it was
about the whole package designer dress
jewelry
shoes you name it go balma or go home
in 2002 designer bradley bayou was ready
to quit the business when he got a phone
call from the queen of daytime herself
oprah winfrey who wore one of his
designs to accept the first ever bob
hope humanitarian award and because the
emmys on our television if you're on a
popular series you get to come back year
after year after year
but there's one actress who graced the
emmy's red carpet for over six decades
betty white is in fact older than the
emmys itself and yet she never shies
away from a good sparkle
recently a new class of tv personalities
have taken red carpet style to a whole
new level embracing personality
authenticity and risk taking and i
personally love it
in 2019 billy porter awed in a
disco-inspired michael kors suit topped
with an asymmetrical custom hat by
british designer steven jones
while last year zendaya's quick change
from christopher john rogers to selena
quintanaea inspired giorgio armani prive
look landed her on every best dressed
list we can't wait to see who wears what
on the next red carpet
did you guys miss the red carpet like i
missed the red carpet are you kidding me
i mean that's our bread and butter i
cannot tell you how i am ready for a
fashion moment thank you so ready for
fashion so what are we going to look for
what are the trends going to be this
year well i'll tell you what they will
be no hoodies no pajamas
i do think you'll see more color from
the men i think that you'll see more i
mean whatever billy porter wears is
going to be fantastic you know he's
going to come back give a moment yeah
he'll have but there will be other
people that give us a moment i mean we
saw tracee ellis ross in that piece
she's going to give us a moment she's
nominated for lead actress in a comedy
and she does fashion for me like no one
on that
[Applause]
i think that we're going to see kaylee
cuoco give us a moment because she gave
us a princess moment when we were at
home and she was nominated for the first
time but we know she's going through a
transition just announced a divorce the
first time we're going to see her after
that i think she's going to give us a
revenge body here i am see my lovely
moment i don't know i think that's going
to well you know sometimes i have to say
that you have got to go out there and
dress with your heart and all of your
spirit and not worry about what
someone's going to say about it yes wear
the red platform here absolutely i think
you'll do that
kiwi herman calls he wants his shoes
[Music]